The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So we began just a
few months ago with this goal
of trying to understand the
scientific study of human
nature, how our mind operates,
why we behave the way we do.
From the brain basis, how we see
and hear the world, how we
think, how we feel, our
predispositions to act in
certain ways, how we develop
from infancy to adolescence to
adulthood, through the
middle ages and into
old age, we all hope.
The remarkably odd things
about human social
interactions, which are
just amazing I think.
And the challenges that so
many people face, with a
degree of vulnerability in these
very kinds of abilities
and behaviors.
And so it's hard to know
what to conclude on.
So I thought I would touch
on two things.
One, sort of fun to think about,
hard to know how to
think about scientifically.
And one, it probably matters
to us all the time.
So let me talk about this.
So when we think about why we
do things, how our brain is
organized, mind is organized,
we know that we've evolved
over a long period of time,
from other species.
And that many things in us
reflect this evolutionary
history, cast into a modern,
unimaginable world from the
viewpoint of biology.
But here we are, sort of
creatures from the past living
in an incredibly accelerated,
changing environment.
And so evolutionary psychology,
people say, let's
try to identify why we have
certain patterns of thoughts
and feelings, given the
evolutionary history of our
minds and brains.
And I'll say a word
about that.
It's tough in many ways though
to have, as much as you
believe that's true, it's got to
be true, it's very tough to
approach scientifically.
Because often, it comes down
to people telling fun,
interesting, clever stories.
Very hard to test.
So we know it's a big part of
who we are, in a deep sense
where we came from.
Very hard to test
experimentally.
But I'll show you a couple
examples where people have
probed this a bit.
And then another question is
in the last decade, some
people have said, well so much
of psychology seems to focus
on the negative, the harm
we're willing to do, the
stereotypes we're
willing to hold.
How about positive psychology?
How about thinking about what
can we learn from psychology
to lead a better, happier,
more meaningful life.
As I'm going to tell you about
the core results about
research about happiness.
And some of them I think
will surprise you.
Some of them, you'll tuck in the
back of your mind maybe,
as you think about what
will make you happy.
I mean we all want to be
happy in a deep sense.
We don't know what's on the
other side of this life.
But we know this is the one
we have in our hands.
And so what can psychology
suggest that might make you
think what's a path
to happiness?
So we talked about throughout
this course about the fragile
power of the human brain.
It endows us with an
unbelievable capacity for
thought, sight, behavior,
vulnerabilities at every
stage, from neurological
injuries to
neuropsychiatric disorders.
And again, we know this all has
grown through this Paul
MacLean triune brain idea, that
within us are kind of a
version of reptilian brains,
within us are simple mammalian
brains, and then finally
the primate and
human expanded neocortex.
And so within us, it's almost
as if we represent in a
certain sense, our species
history, literally in your
brain, literally right now,
in some complex way of
interactions.
With parts of the brain that
have evolved modestly and
parts that evolved spectacularly
in humans.
And the usual story, you're used
to this in evolution, is
that our brains and minds
evolved in nature.
And natural selection was the
dominating part of the story.
Survival of the fittest for
passing genes into the next
generation, that sort of all
stories boil down to that.
And I'm going to tell you
two specific examples.
One that surprised me and then
one that's just sort of fun I
think in a silly way.
So the first one is attitudes
towards race and sex.
And this can came up.
And then the second one is
different attitudes in men and
women, who might have in terms
of sex and procreation.
So let me focus on this
for a moment.
In the last election, you may
remember that there was a
long, grueling race across the
primaries between Hillary
Clinton and Barack Obama.
And in many ways, this is a huge
surprise in the United
States, because with such a
history of racism and sexism,
the idea that the two leading
candidates are a woman and an
African American, was just
kind of an amazing thing.
As much as we had distance
to go, that we
have come that far.
That these were the two
candidates on the Democratic
side, who are competing state
to state across the country,
one of whom would become
the Democratic
nominee and the President.
And I got call from a reporter
from the Boston Globe.
And he said, he was writing a
story saying, which is the
worst problem these candidates
faced, sexism or racism?
And many of us, and I'm no
exception, our egos get turned
up when somebody from
the press calls.
Because our name will
be in the newspaper.
And we can show it to our
friends and family.
And then they know we have a
real job and somebody thinks
we know something.
You laugh.
And the graduate students,
like their parents never
understand anything,
except when their
name gets in the newspaper.
You know how that is, right?
So I thought, well, I'm going to
say something really clever
and all the neuroscience and
all the psychology I know,
either from my own research or
for teaching this course.
I'll have something.
And I just had nothing to say.
I mean we can agree
that racism is bad
and sexism is bad.
And it's kind of excellent that
candidates are beating
those glass ceilings in the
national leadership.
We know from research on things
like the IAT test, that
you heard about, that both
remain a problem.
Negative stereotypes of certain
kinds remain in our
society to this day,
across society.
So I was like, which is worst,
terrible thing A or
terrible thing B?
And I had nothing to say.
And then a newspaper article
came out and said, oh,
according to evolutionary
psychologists, and I was not
included, because I
nothing to say.
This was very sad.
They said well, really Hillary
Clinton faces the harder path.
Because in their mind, sexism
is built into our species.
Because the whole idea of how
we procreate, how men and
women relate in species and
investments, that's deep in
us, all through evolution.
Whereas racism is culturally
specific and malleable.
There's countries where one
group is picked on.
There's countries where another
There's changes in societies.
That's a changeable thing.
This is a tougher thing
to change, was their
interpretation.
I thought well, that
sounds good.
And it might even be true.
It's like a lot of evolutionary
psychology, a
good possibility, a better
answer by infinitely far than
I could give.
But who knows?
And then this one study came
out, that's kind of curious.
So this is a study of children
with Williams syndrome, a rare
disorder, but very studied in
both human genetics and human
psychology.
And partly, it's interesting.
These are the unusual
facial features of
these kinds of children.
They're born this way.
And it's caused by deletion of
26 genes from the long arm of
chromosome 7.
It's one of the most purely
defined and specific genetic
developmental disorders
in humans.
So it's really drawn the
interest of geneticists.
Because it's a disorder that's
really very linked to a very
specific part of the human
genome always.
Distinctive, what they call
elfin facial features,
developmentally delayed
language skills.
And maybe the most curious and
charming element is unusually
cheerful demeanor and
ease with strangers.
These are the children who will
walk up to strangers and
talk your ear off and not be
afraid of anybody or anything.
To an extent that's charming,
can get you in trouble with
the world being the way it is.
It's sometimes contrasted
with autism.
Because individual with autism
find social interactions
sometimes laborious, difficult,
mysterious.
These individuals find it
delightful, nonstop.
You get tired sometimes of
talking to such children,
because they're ready to go
infinitely in terms of social
interaction.
And there's been some study
that they have atypical
amygdala function and lack
of fear response there.
So that's the background about
Williams syndrome.
And then somebody
did a IAT study.
This was in France.
But its been replicated since.
That shows that for these
children with Williams
syndrome, they still have
a gender IAT effect.
That is for example, they're
willing to consider women less
likely to be good at
science and math,
which we know is silly.
But that's the stereotype.
But they showed no racial
IAT effect.
And they had control
participants who showed both.
So now, there's still
interpretation.
But all of sudden, it's as if
this is deeper in the brain.
And maybe this is learned.
And these children aren't
learning this one.
But they can't stop this one.
So a suggestion that there is
something true about this
evolutionary psychology thing.
And that maybe the hardest thing
for us to change deep
down, because of the fundamental
sexual relations
in procreation.
That's a hard thing for us to
work our head around, without
being thoughtful and
careful about it.
So here's an experiment that
was used to demonstrate.
So what's the usual story?
The usual story in evolution
is people on average, not
everybody of course,
wants to have kids.
Because that's how they
pass their genes down.
And who has a lot of investment
per kid, in however
way you look it?
Women.
For women it's, just the first
part is nine months.
And then the immediate
support.
For men, how long is the
minimal contribution?
15 seconds.
OK, well 15 minutes.
It varies.
But you know.
So there's a theory that if the
thing you cared about was
just getting us your genes down
there as much as possible.
Was it Wilt Chamberlain, the
former basketball player, who
said he had slept with
1,000 women.
That he would be like the
champion example in men.
And with women, it's you can't
do a 1,000 nine-month cycles.
So that for men, if that
was the only thing in
life, and it's not.
But here's the experiment
they did.
We couldn't have an
IRB approve this.
But this was done
at a university.
And they said, we're going
to show you an
experiment like this.
And this is meant to
be kind of silly.
But this is how evolutionary
psychology, things are expressed.
And it's kind of
funny, I think.
We'll see.
So what they would do is they
pick take an attractive man
and an attractive woman.
They were the confederates.
And they would approach a
student leaving the library, a
random student.
And here's the responder,
who is a woman.
Imagine yourself as women now,
for those of you who are
woman, leaving a library, kind
of late at night, not too
threatening.
But somebody walks up to you and
says, I've noticed you in
the library a few times.
You seem very nice.
Do you think there's any chance
we could get together
for a date sometime?
What percentage of
women said yes?
In this study, 50%.
Do you think that's high?
Let's pretend it was
a better approach
than what I just said.
I tried to make it low
key and nice, a
low key, nice approach.
For other women, the same male
confederate walks up and says,
I've noticed you in library.
You seem very nice.
What do you about going back
to my apartment and having
some coffee?
We'll take turns then.
Women, what do you think
is the number?
We start with 50.
What?
20.
I noticed you in the library.
You seem very nice.
I think there's something
compatible between us.
What do you think about going
back to my apartment and
having sex right now?
See finally, the course
gets super practical.
I'm not saying it.
This is just one study.
Now, we reverse the roles.
Men, you get ready, all right?
An attractive woman walks up to
you and says, I noticed in
the library.
You seem very friendly.
We seem to be compatible.
Would you be willing to have
a date with me some time?
AUDIENCE: 100%.
PROFESSOR: Would you be willing,
the woman says to the
man, to go back to my apartment
with me right now?
All right, you know
where this going.
An attractive woman walks
up to the man.
And she says, would you go back
to my apartment to have
sex with me this very minute?
The guys got things to do.
You now, he can't--
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: What is the
citation for this?
Let me get that.
I heard it in a talk.
And I saw the numbers.
The numbers are correct.
I have to say when this was
presented, there was some
murmuring, because maybe it
wasn't quite IRB-approved.
I heard it from a good source.
I'll get that for you.
It's in your notes.
So evolutionary psychology,
whatever, it's kind of fun.
But it's hard to know
where it gets you.
But it's definitely
fun to talk about.
So happiness research.
So for a long time, from ancient
philosophy to the
founding of the US and
everything, people said, the
objective of life, as we choose
it, Aristotle, for
itself, and never for
any other reason.
And one of the most amazing
phrases in the Declaration of
independence, "We hold these
truths to be self-evident,
that all men are created equal,
that they are endowed
by their Creator with certain
unalienable Rights, that among
these are life and liberty."
Well, that we would think
would be obvious things, now.
But this amazing thing, "and
the pursuit of Happiness."
As important as life itself
and liberty itself, the
pursuit of happiness.
And I think we know that in our
own lives, as we relate to
other people, as we pursue
careers, as we do things,
where we put our limited
lifetime resources, time and
effort, we all want to end up in
a deep way to be happy and
make the choices to get there.
So we can think on average, you
could think in your head
what makes you happy, what
makes you want unhappy?
And a standard list
might be, people
definitely want to be healthy.
Nobody minds being wealthy.
We'll talk about that.
It never hurts to get
a new car, a new TV,
or new stuff, right?
What makes you unhappy?
Physical injury, emotional
injury.
I mean that would be
kind of standard.
Now, how do you measure
happiness?
And this is the part where you
get us into the funniness of
psychology.
So you have with you a
questionnaire, which is one of
the most widely used measures
of happiness.
So I'll just give you a
moment to look at it.
You could fill it out
for yourself.
We're not going to collect it.
And you may even want
to or whatever.
But just to get a
feeling of this.
And you could say--
oh, sorry.
Anybody else who didn't
get it, that we
could help you with?
A few hands over here.
Oh, thank you.
Again, let me say whoever did
this amazing display is maybe
super happy.
So you're ahead of me.
Thank you.
So it's measured
in life value.
You ask the person like
basically, how happy are you?
And we have a tendency to be
suspicious of just asking
people straight on.
Because if we ask them straight
on, would you say
this line is as big as
this line, if three
other people said that?
You'd say, no, not me.
If you say, would you zap
somebody until you think
they're dead in another room?
You'd say no, not me.
So we're very suspicious about
what people say they will do
and what they really do.
But for happiness research,
it's hard to beat that.
Here's another one.
You can circle the happiness
that represents you.
Because what's the better
question, what's the more
objective measure to decide that
somebody's happy, a brain
image, a blood test?
We don't have a better thing
than the person's own
statement about their
sense of happiness.
All the way back to a Roman
philosopher, "The happy man is
not he who seems thus to others,
but who seems thus to
himself." We don't know of a
better way to ask you if
you're happy, than to
ask if you're happy.
So it's not the most satisfying
kind of objective,
scientific measure.
But maybe it's the life
we lead anywhere.
We decide if we're happy
or not, in some sense.
So if you ask people on average
how happy they are,
2/3 of the people will put
themselves here, almost
everybody above average.
A few people report that they're
consistently unhappy.
And I'm going to come back to
this, but the thing that
struck happiness researchers,
surprisingly modest
influences, and I'm going to
touch this up a little bit
with a research study, of social
status, income, gender,
or ethnicity.
A number of things that you
could have thought would touch
that, surprisingly don't touch
it, or in very limited ways.
But I'll tell you a little bit
about those limited ways.
So on a seven-point scale,
the average is 4 or a 5.
College students, 4.9.
Older people, happier.
We've talk about that before.
Ironically, even though older
people probably face more
challenges in various ways and
limited life spans, they seem
happier by self-report.
One argument that income has
little relationship is this
kind of a graph, that looks at
the average income in the US
from 1930 to 1991.
So here's this increase, that's
not going up anymore.
But it was in the
last century.
And self-reported happiness.
And you can see that at some
point, it goes up, but then it
flattens out.
So the general thought analysis,
I'll show you a
little bit more detail, is, not
much money or in current
situations, poverty,
does strike down
people's sense of happiness.
But once you get above some
threshold, and of course, what
that threshold is varies in so
many ways depending on who you
are and what you expect, but
once you get above some
threshold, that's not
the biggest part
of the story anymore.
And that's pretty much
a general finding.
They've done all kinds
of surveys about
happiness across countries.
It's a really interesting
thing about happiness
research, it's more powerful
than you can imagine in
grabbing hold of the minds of
many people in public policy.
Derek Bok, the former president
of Harvard, has
written a book suggesting that
happiness research ought to be
the basis of public policies
by the government.
That if know what makes people
happy, short of giving
everybody $1 million every year,
why wouldn't you tweak
every policy, even if people
don't think it will make them
happy, but you know from
research it will?
And then here's a world map,
where they surveyed people all
over the place.
The darker the color,
the more people
reported themselves happy.
Now, this is very tricky.
Because now you're in full
scale, there's things like
poverty, but there's also things
like cultural emphases.
In the US, we talk a lot
about happiness.
That concept is less prevalent
in many other cultures,
relatively speaking.
So it's hard to know how much
is the culture, how much is
the actual per capita
income relevant.
But people are pursuing
these things.
And they are finding roughly--
the most recent one, that
again in countries where
there's a lot of poverty, it's
less than in countries where
you start to have
higher incomes.
So poverty is still associated
with less happiness.
And you can guess that
is reasonable.
And then more studies
like this,
again about that direction.
So early on, people said
that income has
nothing to do with happiness.
And that seems not quite right,
especially at the lower
end of poverty.
Now, Dan Kahneman, the Nobel
Laureate, a psychologist at
Princeton, has spent the last
few years talking about what
he calls the focusing
illusion.
And let me tell you
what that is.
It's basically this, when
thinking about one topic, it
could be income, could be
graduate school admissions.
Like whatever the topic is,
fairness, whatever the topic
is, when you're thinking about
that one topic, people tend to
attribute more importance to
that topic than it really has.
They think it accounts for more
of what goes in the world
when they're focused on it.
And you see this all the time
in political discussions.
Like it's all the deficit.
If we just fix the deficit,
everything works.
It's all raising taxes.
If we just do this.
People fixate on one thing.
And then that's the answer
to the whole problem.
That all the time, never mind
political debates where things
might be staged, but
even in one's own
personal life, that happens.
Let me give you an example
of how they
showed that to be true.
They have people rate their
happiness, just like you have.
And then they ask them, and
these were, how many dates for
the single people, how many
dates in the last month?
And they get no correlation
between self-rated happiness
and how many dates you've
had in the last month.
Now they were reverse
for some people,
the order of questions.
How many dates have you had in
the last month and now rate
your happiness.
And they get a positive
correlation.
The more dates you had, the
happier your report yourself.
Well, for people who are dating,
on average, that's a
measure, like getting out there
and meeting people.
It's an average of succeeding
in some path
you want to be on.
So when you just thought about
this, you said, whoa, if I had
no dates this past month, I
must be pretty miserable.
I'm pretty unhappy.
I'm thinking about that.
And all the other elements of
your life that contribute to
happiness, because you
just focused on that.
You just focused on that because
the question was
asked, recede
disproportionately, compared
to the actual importance.
If you go the other way around,
how happy you are, and
you ask this, there's no
correlation, because you're
not thinking about this one
thing and weighting your
overall happiness by this one
question or dimension.
Does that make sense?
So the order is the
whole story.
That people, when they think
about a topic and then think
of how happy or meaningful it
is, they overvalue that topic,
because they just
focused in their
minds on this one dimension.
So getting back to this issue
of income and how that goes
with happiness, here's what
they did, the same thing
again, by asking a specific
question and then asking your
general impression,
the same idea.
So they said, how bad was your
mood the previous day?
So there's a specific
question about mood.
Now, how much time do you think
people with various
income levels are
in a bad mood?
And they picked for example,
people making less than
$20,000 or people making
more than $100,000.
These people who just answered
this question said, gee--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: I don't
see anything.
That's right.
Thank you very much.
The cool thing is now
that they're making
videos of these lectures.
We have so many applicants
to be your peers in
the years to come.
It's going to be unbelievable.
So you guys are great.
So they said it was about 32%
more bad mood, if you were
making less or more.
If you asked people making
how much, it's only a 12%
difference.
It matters, but only
a third as much.
Because you just got
them thinking about
being in a bad mood.
So now they over attribute
income for daily happiness.
And here's a kind of
interesting thing.
And it's a trade-off.
And it gets us to what
is it in your life
that makes you happy.
So people making over $100,000
spend about 20% more time on--
I've got this reversed.
So people making over $100,000
spend more time--
I'll fix the slide up.
Sorry.
Spend more time on doing things
that they report as
being kind of stressful, work,
pressure shopping for the
family, pressured childcare
situations, what they call
obligatory tasks.
And people who make less money,
spend considerably more
time doing things that everybody
considers fun when
they're doing it, socializing,
or watching TV that you like.
So you can see it's
kind of weird.
It's a little bit of where you
put your time and what counts
for you to feel happy
about something.
Everybody's in pretty much
agreement, like you've heard
about almost everything, twin
studies suggest, the set point
of happiness, where you rate
yourself as always
super-happy, moderately happy,
or somewhat grumpy, seems to
be about between 15%
and 80% heritable.
It's as if a piece of us is born
to be super-happy, medium
happy, or chronically grumpy.
There's not a better or worse
way to be, right?
So that people will call
this a set point.
So of course things happen on
a day-to-day basis, on a
moment-to-moment basis, that
push you up or down in
happiness, of course.
You'll get good news, you get
bad new, you have fearful
things, joyful things
coming up.
But the idea is that people tend
to get back pretty fast
to the set point, their level,
whatever that is, of chronic,
constant happiness.
And this is kind of an
amazing finding.
So let's take a look at that
and add one more point.
So here's extroverts by
personality measures and
introverts.
And extroverts report themselves
as being happier.
That's a set point example, a
personality thing that seems
to go over time.
But they share the bumpiness
of the week.
Here's how happy they are on
Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday
whoa, weekend approaching, and
the misery of Sunday, when the
weekend is over.
So you can see in both things,
of course they're responding
to the work week cycle of heavy
work, anticipation of
the weekend, the weekend itself,
and anticipation of
the work day.
Both groups do.
But the set points seem to be
a little bit different, the
chronic, constant level.
Now, there's been a bunch of
ideas about a question about
whether people can
be too happy.
Can a person be too happy?
And here's what they find.
That if they had take people
who say, I'm super, super,
super happy, and you ask them
what's going on their life
that makes some super,
super happy?
Those people often report that
it's close relations to other
people and often, good deeds
or volunteer work, is the
thing that's making them
super, super happy.
A little less happy on average,
but still pretty
happy, are people who have
higher incomes, higher
education, and more political
participation.
So look at these two things.
And you could say in your own
life, but all these things
will matter.
But which is the model of
success for you in your heart,
the human relations and doing
good or the sort of income,
education, active in
your world thing?
And it's not one is
better than other.
It's not you have to choose
one or the other.
But it seems like people
will tend to focus more
on one or the other.
All these things are matter.
But, where you put your heart.
It's easier.
Or you end up doing this,
if you're on the
most extensive happy.
So maybe if you want somebody to
do a certain thing for you,
you don't want them to be so
happy. they have to a little
bit grumbling about stuff.
If you think the world is
perfect, you're not going to
fight for political change.
So what makes us happy?
And it turns out in interesting
ways, it's more
complicated than you think.
And so it's worth thinking
about, because your first
intuitions might not pan out.
So here's an example.
But I want to tell you this,
I'll remind you of this again.
And then switch to
every day one.
So one part of happiness is that
when we reconstruct what
made us happy, what made us
happy growing up as a child;
what made as happy as an
adolescent in high school;
what made us happy last year,
last month, last week, that's
all out of memory.
That's not the current moment
of joy or frustration.
That's your sense of what
was it all about.
Where was I in terms
of happiness?
And so Kahneman again did this
work looking at pain ratings
during a dental procedure.
And he said, what determines
your memory for
how painful it was?
And the two values were the
peak of the pain and the
ending intensity.
So that if you added a little
extra pain at the end, people
actually rated the
whole session in
memory as less painful.
You add some mild pain at the
end, rate it as painful, but
because it was mild, because the
last number that goes in
their algorithm in their mind
is the strength at the end,
and the other number seems to be
the peak, he could predict
pretty well how you would
rate the painfulness
of the entire session.
So this shows you that in many
ways, our minds construct our
definitions of happiness.
They're not simply our
sensory experience.
And here is a thing you could
think about for a moment.
Many of have had jobs
or something.
You haven't had, most of you,
a long work period on a
consistent basis, most
of you I'm guessing.
But think about are you happier
at work or vacation?
So if you ask most people are
you happier at work or
vacation, most people
will say vacation.
That's why I work 50 or 51 weeks
of the year to have that
awesome vacation.
If they do a study where you
carry a beeper on you and they
beep you every once in a while,
unexpectedly, and say,
OK, one to seven, how
happy are you?
And some days you're at the
office and some days you're on
your vacation, what happens?
You report yourself happier
at work, on average.
So that's amazing.
Why do we have vacations
at all?
Not to be miserable.
I mean could you imagine an ad
that said come to our hotel,
you'll be less miserable
than another
hotel on your vacation.
That wouldn't work.
What do think is
going on here?
This is the finding.
What's going on here in the
interpretation is, when we
think ahead about a vacation or
when we reconstruct in our
mind, there's some things
about it that make
us like it a lot.
When we're on the vacation, and
you may know this, and I
think part of it is the
anticipation of vacation
sometimes, what happens?
The hotel wasn't so good.
You got that food poisoning that
ruined the whole trip.
Your brother or sister were
really a nuisance.
Your parents were a drag.
Your parents can't understand
why you were so sulky.
It's was like you didn't have
the space to separate out and
get yourself all sorted out.
I had that too as a kid.
I mean sometimes whatever little
conflicts you had at
home seem to get exaggerated
when you're jammed in
together, for long periods
in cars or
rooms or tents or whatever.
And then you go that home and in
a couple weeks you go man,
that was an awesome vacation.
I'll never forget it.
It means so much to me.
And it's not that you're
faking it.
You really feel that.
Otherwise, you wouldn't get
ready for the next vacation,
the next year.
So what this suggests is, in
ourselves, really there's at
least two ways, or two minds,
thinking about happiness.
One is a moment to
moment happiness.
That's real.
And one is a sort
of big picture,
what is my life about.
And I feel like my life about is
going to interesting places
with people I care about.
That's a vacation.
It's not that people
are hypocritical.
It's that in them there's these
different dimensions of
happiness that are tapped by
different moments of thought.
Happiness researchers, their
most controversial topic,
because they can explain almost
everything in the story
I just told you, is children.
So you talk to parents.
And over 33% will say the single
biggest thing that's
the joy in their life is
having children or
grandchildren.
That's a very common thing.
You could say you're surprised
it's not more.
But still, it's a lot.
It's the single biggest thing.
And I think people really
mostly believe that
when they say that.
If you have people keep a
day-to-day diary, the
moment-to-moment source of
happiness, and they rate one
to seven, everything they just
did, so it's kind of fresh in
their memory, childcare is rated
just over housework,
below sex, socializing with
friends, watching TV, praying,
eating, and cooking.
Because again, it's this
weirdness of like, oh, he's
not doing his homework or
we're afraid she's doing
something or little kids are
just running around, not doing
what you ask them to do.
And it's so frustrating because
you can't get them.
So happiness researchers don't
understand why people have
children at all.
They can't explain it.
There's a lot of effort
going on to come
up with some formula.
And again, it's not that people
will tell you oh, we
can't believe we had kids.
How stupid was that?
They say and they feel, it
is a phenomenal source of
happiness for them.
It's just when you ask them,
how about five minutes ago?
They go, no.
Why did he talk that way?
Why doesn't he or she
listen to me?
Why don't they clean
the room ever?
They're 25 years old.
They could make their bed.
Or whatever.
So it's really interesting,
these two different dimensions
of happiness.
So this idea that within us
there's multiple selves, the
moment to moment self,
that's real.
The big picture, what
is my life about?
That's real.
They're not always perfectly
aligned.
In the US, the moment to moment
happiness, in a recent
study, increases until
about $75,000.
Of course, it's an average.
Depending on what you need to
buy, that number will move.
But then it tops
out on average.
But the big picture, emotional
well-being, but overall
satisfaction keeps going
up with income.
Now, you have to be very
careful on these.
These are all correlations.
Everything I've told you just
about is a correlation.
So when you say overall
satisfaction, sort of big
picture sense of life goes
up with income, is
it really the income?
What else could it be?
Is it literally the size
of your paycheck?
Does it have to be that?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Do you think it might
be what kind of job
you're doing?
PROFESSOR: It might
be the kind of job
you're doing, on average.
And we know there's phenomenally
important jobs
that are underpaid
in this country.
We know that.
But there's a lot of jobs that
are kind of fun to have, that
are decently paid.
Doctors, lawyers, scientists,
a lot of people find those
jobs to be pretty fulfilling
and pretty decently paid.
And there's other
ones as well.
All kinds of jobs are decently
paid, that can be fulfilling.
So it's not necessarily that
it's just about literally
three more dollars and you're
three more dollars happy.
So these correlations
are very tricky.
But again, the sense that moment
to moment tops out at
somewhere here, well
above poverty.
But then, big picture keeps
going up somewhere.
So think for a moment if you
can, just for a moment think
about yourselves five or
10 years from now.
And when you think, if you
can, just for one moment
specifically imagine in your
mind what you might be doing
five or 10 years from now.
And put your hand up
if you thought of
something pretty positive.
A hope.
Put your hand up now
if you thought of
something kind of negative.
Some of you, oh boy.
Most people, our roots claim,
they think about positive
things in the future, other
than fumbling or failing.
So how good are people
at predicting what
will make them happy?
How good are people
at predicting
will make them happy?
What people call affective
forecasting.
So I'll give you two examples.
One that's closer to
my life and one
might apply to everybody.
Actually, I'll tell you
a word about this.
This is a funny story.
If I don't get tenure,
I will be sad.
If I get tenure, I
will be happy.
So you know what tenure
basically is.
You're given a position, a
faculty position, for a
lifetime, unless you do
something really horrible.
So you can't be fired no matter
what you do almost.
You get a lot of freedom
from that.
So on the other hand, what
happens if you don't get
tenure somewhere?
Do you know what happens?
It's not so pleasant,
I could tell you.
It's not the end of
the world at all.
But let me just tell you
what know going in.
What you know going in is your
colleagues are going to meet,
they're going vote.
They're going to say no.
Which kind of hurts because
you've been
there five or six years.
And then you have
to leave town.
OK, you don't have
There could be another
university nearby.
But usually because we're so
super specialized in our
fields, you have to leave town
and go somewhere else.
And you have to tell your
parents, I didn't get tenure.
friends, I didn't get tenure.
And all your friends who you
know from work, will go, oh,
I'm sorry you didn't
get tenure.
For a year, everybody you meet
with goes, I'm sorry you
didn't get tenure.
So you just don't want that.
Well, it's a moment I mean.
None of us want it.
So everybody says, I'd rather
get tenure than not.
Would you rather win the
lottery, than not?
Sure
Happiness researchers
love these things.
So it turns out for a couple of
years after you don't get
tenure, and all the negativity,
and leaving town,
and getting another job, and by
the way, some people have
not gotten tenure and become
amazing superstars, so the
tenure process is often
incorrect in its evaluation.
But two years later,
no difference in
happiness at all.
It doesn't really matter
in the long run.
Winning the lottery, a
year or two later,
no difference either.
There's a whole research field
that runs out the minute
somebody wins a big lottery.
And I had a bit of experience
on this, [INAUDIBLE]
somebody working in my brother's
house won the single
largest lottery, at that time,
prize ever, for an individual
lottery winner in the
United States.
It's been exceeded since.
It was something like
$187 million.
And she was definitely
pretty happy.
And she's been I have to say
remarkably wise since then, in
how she's used the money.
And been a very stable
person, kind of.
But there's equal number of
stories of people who get into
huge trouble.
Actually, the most amazing
story, it's sort of silly to
share, but I have a relatively
short lecture.
This was in the news.
Because you know with the
lottery they say, whoever wins
this will win the
single largest--
there's a huge number
of tickets sold.
And some guy, a taxi driver at
the airport, because all the
news outlets wanted
to cover this.
And they were trying.
Who won?
They knew that there
was a winner.
They didn't know who it was.
And a taxi driver at the airport
supposedly said, I won
the lottery.
I won the lottery.
Now, we knew he didn't, because
we knew this person
had won it.
But all the news channels were
running after this person,
because other cabdrivers
thought he said that.
And then apparently, all the
people he owed money were
hunting him down.
And he had to hire a lawyer to
sort of fight off people.
And so he was really
miserable.
And it was really sad, weird
thing to be the lottery winner
who didn't get the lottery, but
everybody thought you did.
And there's other stories in
towns, these are amazing
stories if you follow it, where
they know somebody won
the lottery in the town.
But the person doesn't
have to come forward.
And then you get all this weird
stuff, because other
people start to guess who really
has a ton of money
amongst them.
And they have wrong guesses.
And they go and say like, my
mother needs medical surgery.
Won't you help me?
And the person doesn't have the
money or maybe that one
does, but most don't.
There's only one.
And so the whole town gets into
huge fights and misery
because they are assuming that
somebody could do amazing
things for everybody, but
they're just being mean
in not doing it.
And 90% of their guesses of
who that is are wrong.
More than you want to know
about lotteries.
But I can tell you that on
average, a year or two later,
no difference.
So it's amazing.
You would think that
would make my life,
if I won the lottery.
And probably it does in
terms of plasma TVs.
But in terms of self-rated
happiness, no difference.
And here's a more amazing thing
in certain way, although
if you talk to patients,
not as amazing.
If you have a unexpected
accident leading to
quadriplegia or paraplegia, so
you really can't get around,
return to typical ratings of
happiness in three months.
So we're incredibly unable to
predict, because we would have
all kinds of ideas about how
long these would brutalize our
sense of happiness.
And we're wrong, wrong, wrong.
We don't know how to predict
what will make us happy.
And some people call
this hedonic
adaptation or a set point.
That you go back to your
set point over
an incredible range.
You do respond.
But you go back to it
over an incredible
range of life outcomes.
So there's a small experiment
compared to these things, but
a controlled experiment.
Dan Gilbert at Harvard, who's
done amazing work in this
area, he had Harvard students in
a photography class choose
their two favorite pictures
from the entire class.
And they were told they have to
give one to their teacher
and they can keep one.
And there were two conditions.
In one condition, once they
gave that picture to their
teacher, that was it.
In the other condition,
they could change the
picture in a few days.
Now, you know in all this
course, every time you think
A, go opposite B, right?
But if you weren't an amazingly
sophisticated
psychologist at this point, if
you were just a person on the
street, which do you think would
sound better, having no
choice or having the possibility
of exchanging the
picture, if you want to,
in a couple of days?
It's a choice.
We like choice, right?
No.
The people who are happier are
the people who say once hand
me the picture, that's to me.
These people are standing around
going, I don't know.
I don't know.
Where am I going to
be happier, this
picture or that picture?
I don't know.
I can't tell.
Also once it's an irrevocable
choice, what amazing human
thing comes into play
that helps us feel
good about our lives?
Cognitive dissonance.
Did I pick the right picture?
That teachers is a sucker.
I thought they were
the two best.
But the one that teacher took,
oh, that was pretty bad.
I can't believe how lucky I am
that irrevocably I ended up
with this picture.
The person who has days to do
this, they can't let cognitive
dissonance come in and
fix up their choice.
The paradox of choice, why
choices can be painful.
So again, we like choice.
I like choice.
There's an experiment.
People say, you go into a
typical big grocery store, 285
cookie choices, 13 sports
drinks, 75 ice teas, 200
channels and more, on cable.
So they did an experiment in
Palo Alto, Stanford's group,
in a gourmet food store.
They had exotic, high-quality
jams.
And you could taste some jams.
And then get a coupon for $1
off if you buy the jam.
So a typical kind of
thing you might see
sometimes in grocery stores.
And they would have you taste
either six jams or up to 24.
Now, most people didn't
do 24 jams.
Because you wouldn't want to
have that many, even single
tastes of a jam.
But you'll try a few, at
a table like this.
So first of all, here's
the two tables.
Six jams or 24.
More shoppers came to
the table of 24.
Well, you see 24
jams out there.
It's kind of impressive.
Like there's got be something
I like there.
What's going on?
So more people are drawn to
the big choice department.
Now when they get there, they
only have about five jams.
These people have about six.
So it's about the same number
of jams that you taste.
Big display, lots of choice.
Limited choice.
What happens in your
actual behavior?
Well, at the six-jam table,
30% of the people
purchased the jam.
If there's a 24-jam table, only
3% made the purchases.
So what do you think happened?
We don't know for sure.
This is the actual behavior.
Exactly the opposite, more
choices among jams led to less
purchases of jams.
What's your guess as
to what happened?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: They people who liked
[INAUDIBLE] with 24
jams, were in a jam.
PROFESSOR: Were what?
AUDIENCE: They're in a jam.
PROFESSOR: They're in a jam.
That's pretty good.
They were in a jam.
Yes.
And because what?
Because I tried five or six,
it's all I could try.
But there's another
20 out there.
And they could be awesome
beyond belief.
And I'm not going to commit.
Because there could be some
awesome jam around the corner.
And I've only tried
five or six.
So they're overwhelmed.
Instead of happily getting
a jam, they're
jammed up as you said.
Ah, ah.
And they go, um, who can begin
to figure out what's the right
jam for me.
It's just a way too big.
So all those choices make them
less likely to make a
purchase than this.
Exactly the opposite of what
might intuitively-- too many
choices are burdensome.
Calling plans.
I don't know if you've ever
tried to compare calling plans
across phone services.
You sit down for a few moments
and you just give up.
Maybe you don't.
Health insurance things,
retirement plans.
You just get all these
complicated menus.
And a lot of people
just give up.
And they just go like,
what's the cheapest?
What do most people do?
Because it's just too
hard to figure out.
So when they do surveys of
asking people what people
think will make them
happy, these are
the most common answers.
If I get into a relationship
or a marriage that I like.
If I have more flexibility
at work.
Getting a baby, if that's
what you want.
Losing weight, cure of a chronic
disease, making more
money, having more time,
advancing in beauty.
OK, this is the list.
It's not surprising
list, right?
What would make you
more happy?
And again, we know that
happiness set
points are about 50%.
10% estimated the circumstances,
like poverty.
Things that you can't
help in your life.
Just can't help.
But happiness researchers are
trying to make the case that
about 40% of our happiness
depends on what
we choose to do.
So that's a big piece.
It's a big piece.
We can't help some things, in
our genes or in our global
environment.
But it's almost half.
And these are estimates.
Maybe it's more.
But this is the current
estimate.
And research, over and over
again, shows that it's wrong
to think that happiness
is found.
Like you get there.
And here I am, happy.
That it's changing in
your circumstances.
I move in a city.
I get a promotion.
I meet another person.
That's the happiness.
And that you either have
it or you don't.
I'm just a person
who's not happy.
All these things, the objective
evidence is against.
And here's what researchers find
goes with, in experiments
and in correlations.
Here's their list, from an
objective evidence as they can
get, in this kind of work.
Time nurturing relations with
family and friends comes out
as the number one thing
that plays out.
Expressing gratitude
and helping others.
Whole experiments were if you
just did something nice,
people feel awesome.
I heard a Berkeley psychologist
say, just try to
feel unhappy after you
just expressed
gratitude or helped somebody.
And you can't even do it.
I don't know if that's
quite true.
But experiments have shown
that when you have people
express gratitude or do
something to help others,
their happiness ratings
will zoom right up.
Practicing optimism about the
future, savoring life in the
present, physical exercise,
commitment to lifelong goals
and ambitions.
A sense that you have a path
that make sense to you, as
opposed to sort of bumping
around from opportunity and
opportunity.
And something about, having
an approach to coping or
resilience when bad
things happen.
I'm sure in some of your lives,
heartbreaking, bad
things have happened.
Most of us get some of them.
Many of us get every day things
that we struggle with.
And the path by which we deal
with adversity, huge influence
on self-reported happiness.
So again, so this is
my final slide.
And I hope that this course,
you guys have made me happy
throughout this course.
I've have incredibly pleasurable
lunches and
dinners and brunches with
students from the course.
This is just stunning for me.
And it's really moving.
And I'm just very grateful
to have had the chance to
introduce you to these ideas.
Have a OK exam period.
You have to get through that.
Bounce back and cope.
And have a great summer.
Thanks very much.